francine lacquer spoke exclusively to
hedge fund billionaire george soros who
says the situation in the east of europe
is deeply concerning and that without
external financial assistance ukraine
will deteriorate francine asked him how
he rates the new government so far
their task is
you know
immense and they haven't done everything
right
and
the reforms
have actually been rather slow
and they're just beginning
to uh beginning to to see the the actual
performance and
practically every day there is a
an advance
but very interestingly
what happens is ukraine is up against
not only
putin's russia but also
what i call the old ukraine
there is a new ukraine that wants to be
the opposite of the old ukraine but the
old ukraine is still there mr sars there
are two scenarios the west becomes
tougher
unites politically or the west continues
as it is
what happens if the west continues as it
is how bad is it going to get well there
are two possibilities one is that you
create ukraine actually collapses this
is putin's
sort of
optimum
goal
to have a financial collapse political
infighting
and he can
then step back and say i didn't cause it
i'm a good boy
so
lift the sanctions that's what he hopes
for
i'm very pleased to say we're joined now
by francine lacroix who brought us that
exclusive conversation with george soros
francine the bit of this interview that
i really really liked was the fact that
he thinks that they can make an example
of russia by making sure that ukraine
succeeds what's your take well he was
very feisty he's very passionate about
ukraine he basically says this was a
problem that was mishandled from the
start what he's trying to do is
basically spur uh the international
community the west to try and be more
proactive now i asked him about money i
asked him you know how do you become
more proactive and he says it's a show
of unity he says it's very difficult at
the moment for europe and the west to
show that unity at the moment because
they're just too distracted with greece
so he he links the two it's very clear
that he's passionate about ukraine
because he says this is a unilateral
change of borders and it's just unfair